es gab wie in den vergangenen tagen und
wochen auch eine demonstration vor dem
parlament und da ist dann die polizei
aufgetaucht wie auch häufiger in den
vergangenen tagen hat mit festnahmen
begonnen ein dutzend menschen wurden
festgenommen
und die anderen sind dann geflüchtet in
eine angrenzende katholische kirche die
würde umstellt von sicherheitskräften
von spezialkräften und man hat dann
diese kirche verschlossen wie menschen
konnten nicht mehr raus am ende durften
sie die kirche dann wieder verlassen
haben wir sehen dass die polizei hier
diesen vergangenen tagen immer härter
vor geht nach dem sonntag wo wir diese
beeindruckenden bilder gesehen haben von
hunderttausenden menschen auf der straße
besucht die polizei vor allem die
kleineren demonstrationen hier zu stören
und sie macht druck bei
internetanbietern du hast es gerade
gesagt gestern als es dann zu diesen
dramatischen situationen kam ging
plötzlich das mobile internet vor ort
nicht bergen